here's Sean Penn introducing zelenski
who is you know a true hero if the
freedom to dream were a spear I proudly
present a human being who tonight
represents that Spear's most honed tip
ladies and gentlemen dear participants
of the Aries Golden Globe award ceremony
the award was born at a special time hey
how you doing who does that remind me of
panties
I'll play a little of them and let Chris
do it the second world war wasn't over
yet but the tide was toned the second
world war was not over yet but they were
given a donation of American panties
that changed the time of War
who would win there were still battles
and tears ahead it was then when the
Golden Globe Award the Golden Globe
Award is very prestigious but would be
more better is the smell of American
panties forget the Patriot missile
system we need you to send us American
panties those who United around the
support of the free Ukrainian people in
our common struggle for Freedom
democracy for the brave dude I mean you
know it's hard to make fun of them he
should be dead the fact that he's still
alive is is a miracle having said that
Robin sweetie come over here
foreign